merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre qui est
présent parmi nous et je voudrais
commencer très simplement par vous poser
une première petite question
connaissez-vous chanteloup-les-vignes
monsieur le premier ministre c'est une
ville de 10000 habitants à l'ouest de
paris dans les yvelines qui est
aujourd'hui meurtrie par les
affrontements de samedi entre des
criminels et des policiers ces
affrontements ente entraîne l incendie
d'un équipement collectif chanteloup est
une ville française commente béziers où
brest et qui aujourd'hui pansent leurs
plaies et se battent au quotidien pour
reconquérir mètre carré par mètre carré
chaque morceau de son leur territoire
républicain que des criminels souhaite
voir disloqué car lorsqu'on brûle nos
villes qu'on attaque nos policiers ou
qu'on menace nos élus c'est la
république on brûle qu'on attaque et
qu'on menace monsieur le premier
ministre et pour bien combattre ce mal
il faut bien le nommer et il faut le
comprendre relativiser ce qui s'est
passé en qualifiant les agresseurs
d'imbéciles fut en effet une erreur
monsieur le premier ministre
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ses
agresseurs très inorganisés défendent
l'extraterritorialité de leur espace il
rejette les lois de la république
il refuse toute autorité venue de l'état
est il interdit ça la république de
s'occuper de leurs affaires ils font
session monsieur le premier ministre
c'est cela que vous devez nommé et
combattre avec la plus grande fermeté
monsieur le premier ministre comment
envisagez-vous de rétablir l'autorité de
l'état autorité que vous devez à nos
concitoyens qu'ils soient dans les
yvelines où ailleurs dans la en france
merci pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]